the jurgen experience
your kids just cut loose on youtube
no no no no no no no no luckily one of
my kids all she likes to watch on
youtube is like there's a girl named
sniper wolf
who's very funny and she does like these
reaction videos to stuff but it's very
g-rated and she loves watching her
and you know
there's
you know but i keep an eye on what
they're doing and i don't allow them to
just start going crazy yeah because it's
just you just
you know you never know i mean one day
you just stumble upon an isis beheading
video yeah and now you have you know
your kids [ __ ]
waking you up in the middle of like
crying and screaming because they can't
get this image out of their head it's
terrifying it is to be on the other side
of it too because when you're young all
you want to do is
throw off the chains oh yeah
and then all of a sudden you're like in
the position of putting the chains on
yeah you gotta it's like how much
freedom do you give them like how much
do you talk to them about stuff how much
do you let them figure this stuff out on
their own
you know
it's uh it's tricky and it's a weird
world because it didn't exist previously
like it's not like we're dealing with
something that we went through when we
were children there was no google when
we were children there was no you know
live leak you ever go on live leak no
[ __ ] i know about it but yeah
horrible videos you can watch a lot of
car accidents and animal attacks and
just wow yeah yeah that's not you know i
have been on that yeah i have i have
stumbled into that but that was that
didn't exist before when i was a kid if
you wanted to watch something [ __ ] up
you had a plan for it like we wanted to
watch faces of death somebody had to get
the video some one of our friends had to
watch the door you know so like we were
in the basement one of the friends had
to wash the door make sure the parents
didn't come down and then we put it on
the vcr and we we were ready like if
someone came down you'd pop that [ __ ]
tape out and hide it
these kids today all they have to do is
just have a phone you know and a lot of
times kids are 11 and 12 they have
phones
and 12 year olds with a phone i mean
they're going to start googling
people [ __ ] people getting killed
they're going to see the most crazy [ __ ]
have you seen this your friend's gonna
say have you seen that and then you're
gonna look on your phone there's
there's no way to stop it there's no way
to stop it kids have wild [ __ ]
workarounds for for like little
restrictions my sneaky little [ __ ]
kid you know what she did
she screen recorded
um my wife when my wife went and put in
a password
for her screen time yeah nice move very
nice move she handed her phone over to
my wife my wife goes in and puts a
password in for her screen time so she
can only get an hour's worth of screen
time a day and then my wife checks and
she's like how [ __ ] you have four hours
of screen time like what's going on here
so she and then she figured out that the
really the little monster yeah did you
guys have public access
when you were growing up like public
access tv i used to oh yeah
that's my first exposure to faces of
death was after 10 o'clock
they could show whatever the [ __ ] they
wanted for whatever reason really
not blatant porn but porn
really i saw that's what the bud die
dwyer video of him shooting himself in
the face you saw that on tv to the 21
gun salute when i was going to bed and i
was when i was like 10 years old what
yeah huh no way wow and then this guy
ended up i was talking with some of my
friends when i was back at home in my
reunion this guy was we all knew about
him when we were like 12 13 years old
had a show
painted up like an insane clown posse
type character
and would have like blood
girls
vaginas lips all sorts of wild [ __ ]
really wild and it was just like the
government was putting it on technically
because of public access so in public
access there's no restrictions like
there are so i was asking i don't i did
not you guys didn't have that's like
what wayne's world was that's my only
thing i knew growing up was like wayne's
world on the snl was a public access
show but then we actually had public
access and that's where wild [ __ ] was
happening after 10 o'clock i had a
friend of mine who wrote a public access
show my friend uh larry ropucci was a
stand-up comic in uh i think it was
larry's show but he was a stand-up comic
in boston we all did a public access
show when we were like struggling
comedians we all went you did it too
yeah i wore a dress i wore a dress and a
wig and i was like we had like a like a
dating show and
this is the wild guy that i would this
is from the 90s i think i found it on
youtube it's still exciting it's like
very david lynch man so it's just so
weird to watch
also he would that's him on the right
and him on tv oh so he really planned
this out just some weird [ __ ]
wow this is nice he's doing coke these
the tampons it's also like again i was a
kid when i was seeing this stuff wow so
like to me
looks like robert smith from the cure
man someone found him i don't know i'm
sure he's like on facebook or he's
probably doing this stuff still let's
find him well
he's going to find out oh jesus christ
oh yeah
so he got away with this this was all on
yeah but he wasn't even the only one
there was a clown called like angsto the
clown that was like i'm sure redman
knows about this stuff because he was a
little bit older than me in the same
area that's probably why he he was
probably watching the same way
this is why it might make sense now
wherever he brought up columbus ohio
weird there's i mean this and then
looking back into some of the stuff that
was happening there it kind of makes a
little bit of sense but if this isn't
wasn't going on everywhere that's sort
of like the strange thing i never saw it
in boston but i might have been out of
the loop it might have might have
existed i just wasn't aware of it but i
thought the regulations were across the
board if you were broadcasting i didn't
think that public access was different
is it because it's local
maybe and then there's like
free speech laws that we're getting into
i i don't again i was a kid so i have no
idea i was just i was excited to see it
i just i haven't it's not
it won't be available until spring but
um
for the last couple years i've been
working on a
book
you know like this is the thing i
thought i'd never do i used to be
annoyed by people who thought about
their kids before i had kids but
i have a book that i just finished
called uh outdoor kids inside world and
it's about
you know kids in nature
raising kids
and yeah man if you'd asked me dude like
10 years ago i'd been like no way i
would do something like that but it's
just harrowing man it's like scary what
is scary having kids oh okay yeah
yeah worried about them and just like
yeah and like trying to guide their you
know guide their experience you know and
for me oh yeah i found that
um
[Music]
that that
ex you know exposure to nature
experiences in nature understanding
nature is like winds up being an avenue
of approach that i have with them
that works for both of us it's like a
common language you know yeah but yeah
man it's it's it's it's terrifying and
the the
the feeling of
the hypocrisy that you get
of
things that meant
that when you were young things that
meant a lot to you and felt very
authentic to you
like freedom
freedom to consume what media you wanted
freedom to talk to who you wanted to
talk to freedom to go where you wanted
to go
um the
later you're in a position where you're
[Music]
um
denying
denying someone something that you
really wanted in an honest way when you
were young yeah
um it's a push and pull man jonathan
hate about that
you know he talks about the the concept
of free-range kids
about he lets his children wander it was
jonathan hate right
was right the coddling of the american
mind um he lets his kids wander around
new york city like he lets his kids walk
home from new york city and you know
he's talking about one time his uh his
kid got a little lost and they were
really really scared you know it was
like they were trying to find them and
it's like a terrifying feeling
but that ultimately
the
development that the child receives from
being able to navigate the world on
their own is very valuable but there's a
risk and so you like have to weigh this
risk versus reward
and the opposite of that is people do
helico helicopter parent and we know how
that turns out right that's not good
when you overly coddle your kid and your
your kid is not exposed to any sort of
adversity or any sort of danger or any
sort of adventure or any sort of
independence that it can be stifling and
then it takes a long time for the child
to develop outside of that parental
environment once they become free
they're like there's different kinds of
kids right there's kids that grow up in
bad neighborhoods with very little
parental guidance and they're 18 and
then there's kids who grow up completely
coddled and completely protected and
insulated and they're 18 and then they
run into each other
totally different life experiences yeah
and i was the former you know i was the
kid that didn't have a lot of guidance
when i was a kid and i was kind of a
lock key a latchkey kid i'm glad you
just used that word yeah that's common
word right common phrase well apparently
it's not no i grew up with that word
yeah
i was commenting on how my wife in her
early years was a latch key kid and
she's like i haven't heard that word in
a long time that used to be a word dude
like latch key kid yeah you got a key
you got a key and yeah you get you came
home and no one was home you know when i
was 12 years old yeah just i mean it
wasn't like five days ago someone was
pointing out to me that that word
doesn't get used anymore yeah well kids
don't i mean it's kind of a different
thing you don't really see 12 year old
kids walking home with a key and opening
up their front door anymore
i mean i think about my children and how
young they are and i can't imagine them
doing that but i did that and i think
that the independence that comes from
being a kid who walks home from school
by yourself and opens your door by
yourself and you know and then
my parents didn't come home till you
know whatever was they worked till five
and then they were home
i was out i would go places no one knew
where the [ __ ] i was there was no phones
there's no cell phones you know i could
leave a little post-it note or something
like that
it's it's been interesting to watch
um
as a parent the way that you that
different parents find
what dangerous things they're
comfortable with
um friends of mine like my friend kelly
lives in new york right and she'll talk
about
and we have
similar mindsets um about
exposing kids the risk
and
her kids will take the subway right or
whatever home
and to me where i where where i live and
have not had kids that age in the city
like i can't picture what she's getting
at
you know i mean i go like wow that seems
just kind of like crazy yeah
how old are you irresponsible uh
i'm trying to think about 14 and 9 or 10
somewhere in there
um and now they've been at it for a
while but either way like things that
some people regard things that people
from the outside would regard as like
hard to picture you know yes sort
but at the same time
i expose my kids to like danger that i
have decided is like an okay danger to
court i'll expose them to being
you know
they can be around grizzly bears they
can be unescorted in areas that have
a lot of mountain lions and bears we
take small boats out in the very big
water
um we do all kinds of things but it's
like things that i've decided are um
good risk
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify